[Music]
for our daily cancellation
we dive back into our country's racial
hysteria in order to cancel npr for this
editorial just published yesterday
titled tom hanks is a non-racist it's
time for him to be anti-racist
now tom hanks as you may have heard
recently published his own editorial
about the tulsa race massacre where he
argued that history
the history we're taught focuses too
much on white people and glosses over
our racist past
basically making a similar argument to
the one advanced by joy reid
and robert reich in our opening tom
hanks in fairness though
is uh not as stupid as joy reid but then
again tom hanks's volleyball and
castaway
isn't as stupid as joy reid pretty low
bar to get over in any case
the point is that tom hanks is a white
celebrity
who wrote an op-ed to discuss the evil
of racism and the alleged white washing
of history and so on
if you haven't been paying attention you
might think this this would please
the the left-wing race activists they'd
be happy about it
they would say oh thanks tom hanks for
supporting us
but because you haven't been paying
attention you don't realize that their
whole game is to not ever be pleased by
anything
that's what gives rise to this article
in npr from a guy named eric degens eric
gives hanks a nice pat on the head and a
sticker for his effort but then he
explains
that he's still very disappointed he
writes quote
when i saw hanks that when i saw that
hank's had recently written a guest
essay for the new york times calling for
more widespread teaching about the tulsa
race massacre
when white mobs in oklahoma burned a
prosperous black neighborhood to the
ground in 1921 killing between 100 and
300 people
i was sincerely heartened now i thought
we'll see him examine how his work so
often focused on the achievements of
virtuous white male americans
and may have made it tougher for tales
about atrocities such as tulsa to find
similar space
but he didn't fully go there he then
quotes a few lines from hank's pieces
from hank's piece and then says quote
these are wise words
and it's wonderful that hanks stepped
forward to advocate for teaching about
a race-based massacre indirectly pushing
back against all the
ventilating about uh critical race
theory that's too often more about
silencing such lessons on america's
darkest chapters
but it is not enough
and of course it isn't it never is tom
hanks
could have ran through the streets
weeping
and whipping himself and screaming i'm
sorry i'm sorry
and it still would not have been enough
but in this case tom hanks had the
audacity to not apologize at all
and eric degens is quite upset about
that he continues after many years of
speaking out about race and media in
america
i know the toughest thing for some white
americans especially those who consider
themselves
advocates against racism is to admit how
they were personally and specifically
connected to the elevation of white
culture over other cultures
in other words he is a baby boomer star
who has built a sizeable part of his
career on stories about american white
men
doing the right thing he's not alone
superstar director steven spielberg has
a similar pedigree non-withstanding
occasional projects like the color
purple
and amistad and fellow director ron
howard
these stories of white americans
smashing the nazi war machine or riding
rockets into space are important
but they often leave out how black
soldiers returned home from fighting in
world war ii
to find that they weren't allowed to use
the gi bill to secure home loans in
certain neighborhoods
or were cheated out of claiming benefits
at all
yes um well it would have been sort of
strange to include that in saving
private ryan
where would you have included the
information about the gi bill in saving
private ryan what did he expect maybe we
could have had the final scene
of an old matt damon standing at tom
hanks's grave
thinking about whether or not he had
earned this and then quickly it would
cut to a black man being denied
use of the gi bill then roll credits
or better yet they can do a remake of
saving private ryan where matt damon's
character survives the war
and then ironically becomes a nazi and
at the end he's assassinated by
a black disabled non-binary lesbian
ninja
i mean i don't mean to give hollywood
any ideas but this really is the point
that the writer is making he's angry
that tom hanks
portrays white people doing good things
white people are villains eric diggins
believes and that is their rightful role
in any film
to close out the piece degens gives hank
some homework assignments or
action items to use modern parlance he
says quote
if he really wants to make a difference
hanks and other stars need
to talk specifically about how their
work has contributed to these problems
and how they will change
they need to make specific commitments
to changing the conversation and story
subjects casting and execution
that's the truly hard work of building
change rather than talk about the
historically based fiction entertainment
uh what it must do why not talk about
what tom hanks
long time scripted and documentary
executive producer will do
as a star who can get a movie made just
by agreeing to appear in it
what will tom hanks movie star actually
do
people often say columns such as the one
by hanks are published to start a
conversation well
here's my suggestion let's make part of
that conversation how baby boomer
filmmakers have made fortunes amplifying
ideas of white american exceptionalism
and heroism
and now their responsibility now now
lies
with uh helping dismantle and broaden
the ideas that they help cement
in the american mind yes we would want
to cement the idea
that white people do good things that's
very dangerous you know
it's dangerous to give people the
impression that white people are capable
of
positive actions the safest and best
thing is to place an entire race of
people in the villain role
and uh keep them there because as we've
seen through history that always works
out well right
all this of course is racist nonsense
this is a man who simply hates white
people and can't contain it
and fortunately for him he doesn't have
to contain it we can only imagine the
reaction to an editorial arguing
uh arguing that there shouldn't be
movies that amplify ideas of black
heroism
can you imagine an editorial about i
don't know black panther
where it's a white a white writer saying
you know i
this movie's a little problematic
because uh it kind of gives this idea of
black heroism and
i'm unsure about that i think can you
imagine that you can't imagine it
or rather you can only imagine it
because such an editorial could never
actually be published and even if it
could
there isn't anyone who would be
interested in writing it
but that doesn't satisfy eric degens
nothing
ever can or will it's not enough for tom
hanks to denounce racism
he needs to actively demonize white
people in his films
eric has given hanks his marching orders
his next movie must be a story about a
wealthy white republican oil executive
discriminating against a bisexual native
american climate activist
and then in the end he has to be thrown
down an oil well
and as he's falling asked to shout i'm
white and evil and i'm sorry
just to make sure the point was clear
anything less than that
and hanks will be a part of the problem
and the problem for degen
is that there isn't enough anti-white
sentiment out there
and there never will be because that's
how it's all set up
that's why npr and eric daggen are
most assuredly canceled listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated